depuis le 18 mars
pretty travaille à l'institut
universitaire de santé mentale de
montréal elle a sa carte d'employé et
fait équipe avec deux psychoéducatrice
ok on est au bureau en fait la rédaction
avait trop bu reau le savait son moment
de repos mais cela nous suit le
quotidien dans nos rencontres
pretty fait trois visites par jour dans
les centres d'hébergement desservies par
le réseau de la santé de l'est de
montréal
j'aime beaucoup ce cas kg mais c'est
quand même une autre configuration de
nos malades puis on sent lui fallait un
peu moins madjer le chien chez comme le
bonheur et avoir l'amour
amedi beaucoup pascal riché comprennent
beaucoup les gens la personne tels qu'un
où un homme ou une femme qui sont
malades
l'idée d'un chien mira s'est imposé
après avoir expérimenté la zoothérapie
en 2015
ça donnait des très bons résultats mais
malheureusement ça coûtait très cher on
peut pas offrir le suivi à plusieurs
personnes
la fondation de l'institut des bourses
5000 $ par année pour soutenir pretty
qui a été sélectionnée est dressée comme
chien d'assistance en soutien émotionnel
par mira le chien en tant que telle ne
fera pas grand chose mis à part sa
présence
donc c'est vraiment de la façon que
l'intervenant va travailler avec le
chien sa grande grande force c'est son
tempérament fait souvent pour des
problèmes de comportement chrétiens à ce
moment là pour venir nous aider à
établir le lien plus rapidement avec la
personne à peu se soucier redonner la
motivation à un client d'aller marcher à
l'extérieur prédit pratiques auxquelles
on a une clientèle qui précédente à ça
peut faire des mots des années qu'ils
sont pas sortis d'avoir prêté
saddamistes le petit coup de pouce pour
retourner marché elle est assise avec
des chercheurs de l'institut on évaluera
scientifiquement la contribution de
pretty mais déjà sa présence semble
bénéfique pour l'instant elle vraiment
bien accueilli le tout le monde adore
prg est il vraiment oui on a des
sourires sur les visages qu'on voyait
plus de sourires comme chien par exemple
à peu apaisées à peu favorisés en fait
les convenances aussi quand c'est
nécessaire prouve que quand on parle et
chante en tout cas jeté une pièce qu'on
dit thacker chier chez vous avez bonne
brique du sacré comme jean derrey
beaucoup à lui
oui ici anne louise despatie radio
canada montréal